do you ever think that human evolution
is
a little slow
what if we cranked up the speed and had
you evolved 1 000 years in one day
in what ways would your appearance
change
how would new technology shape your life
and how would it change the way you
think
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you evolved 1 000 years in one
day
about 10 000 years ago
your ancestors spread to every continent
on earth
except for antarctica
they had already started to farm herd
animals and settle down into villages
with all the changes in our living
conditions since then
humans have evolved 100 times faster
than at any other time
in the last 150 years we've grown 10
centimeters and started living an
average of 20 years longer
fast forward another 1 000 years of
human evolution and could it be possible
to live forever
if you jump-started your evolution and
evolved 1 000 years overnight all the
changes might feel
a little awkward
for starters you might become smaller
yeah you would be living on an
overcrowded planet with scarce resources
our bodies might conserve more energy
this would come with a certain amount of
growing pains or rather shrinking pains
but you would wake up feeling better
than you did the day before
that's because tiny nanobots inside your
body would be enhancing your natural
abilities
these nanobots would be small
about 1 100 of the width of a strand of
hair
and they could monitor every aspect of
your body's health
if you have diabetes for example
these little workers would regulate your
glucose and insulin levels
you could discover that compared to your
unevolved friends
you're suddenly thinking faster
yeah your brain would benefit from
advanced artificial intelligence that
would be as fast if not faster than the
human brain
with such advanced ai
you could do things that are impossible
by today's standards
maybe you could see frequencies outside
the visible spectrum because special
cameras would enhance your eyes
you'd be able to recognize faces and
names at lightning speed
your mind would have its own version of
facebook let's call it brain book
you could find that you suddenly have a
new grasp of languages
so you could discover that you now speak
mandarin or cantonese
these could be the standard global
language in the future
considering that
1.39 billion people speak chinese today
now if you still understand me
that could mean that english has
retained its position as a global
language
it could also be that you now understand
and speak all languages
this would be thanks to advanced
translation enhancers in your brain
you could talk to anyone anywhere
without ever needing to learn the
language
but if those enhancers in your brain
stopped working
you would discover that
maybe you aren't that much smarter than
your peers
you could take a quick intelligence test
to find out you aren't even as smart as
you used to be
this could be because your brain evolved
to be dependent on all these new
developments in ai
without their assistance
simple tasks you perform at work
could seem complex and challenging
the most dramatic change of all is one
you wouldn't notice right away
but eventually you would discover that
your life expectancy has extended
to around 150
years
that would be thanks in some part to the
nanobots monitoring your health but it
would also be due to genetic
modifications that could become
commonplace in the future
your genes would be engineered to remove
diseases like cystic fibrosis or
huntington's disease
all these new developments in your body
would feel unique and special if they
happen to you overnight
but with all these changes occurring to
humanity over the next 1 000 years
you'd find that we would all start to
look and act the same
like clones of each other
maybe by that time
we would be clones
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]